[Musique]
c'est par jour aujourd'hui
mais moi aujourd'hui je quitte ma life
au bangladesh alors vous chercher tous
des solutions pour changer le monde
vous êtes venus pour ça aujourd'hui
alors j'ai pas de remède miracle j'ai
pas de baguette magique pour vous
j'aimerais bien qu'on appuie sur un
bouton et qu'on puisse arrêter tous les
sujets qui nous qui nous polluent
beaucoup c'est à dire le réchauffement
climatique les guerres toutes ces choses
là
par contre ce que j'ai à vous dire
aujourd'hui ça pourrait bien changer
votre vie et pas seulement la vôtre pour
ça je suis venu vous parler de votre
placard alors un placard c'est quoi un
placard c'est quelque chose où orange ce
qu'on mange ou orange
les vêtements comporte un placard ça
peut aussi être un endroit où on cache
des choses pour m'aider secret je ne
vais avoir un amant des fois au placard
un placard c'est tout ça mais un placard
c'est plus grand que ça passe que dans
un placard
en fait il ya de l'espoir et l'espoir
c'est de l'espoir de reprendre votre
pouvoir
où est votre pouvoir à vous l'espoir
d'agir l'espoir d'une nouvelle vie
et comme je suis sûr que dans l'un de
vos placards
vous avez des chaussures on va commencer
par un petit film qui a été produit par
une ong qui s'appelle sunwing en
autriche et je vous propose qu'on
regarde ça ensemble
[Musique]
sam
cet instant
[Musique]
alors là on parle de chaussures mais on
pourrait parler de plein d'autres
produits vous en avez vu des vidéos
comme ça est ce que je vous propose
maintenant c'est de ressentir un petit
peu ce que ce type de message créée en
vous et en général il ya quatre types de
mes deux réactions à l'intérieur de nous
face à ce type de message la première
réaction c'est une réaction de dénis je
vois ce film j'y pense et puis j'oublie
la deuxième réaction c'est une réaction
de culpabilité c'est à dire que vous
avez quand même un malaise à voir ce qui
se passe à l'autre bout du lacet mais ça
va pas créer ou en vous gâte vraiment un
changement
donc ça c'est la culpabilité la
troisième réaction possible c'est de la
colère on entend des gens qui souvent
disent on est pris dans un système on
peut rien faire et la 4e réaction est
une réaction de changement c'est à dire
vous voyez ce film est à l'intérieur de
vous vous dites la prochaine fois que
j'achète une paire de chaussures ça va
se passer autrement dénis colère
culpabilité on va retrouver à peu près
85 % des gens et on va trouver casse
pour sont des gens qui sont dans la
partie changement alors qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on passe de ces réactions de
déni de culpabilité de colère au
changement c'est pas des super héros là
les 15% c'est pas des gens qui ont une
baguette magique non plus en fait ces
gens là ce sont des gens qui en général
ont vécu à l'intérieur d'eux une rupture
plus ou moins graves est en fait ce que
je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui c'est
ma rupture à moi de dire la façon dont
je rêvais qu en espérant quand je vais
vous raconter mon histoire ça va
peut-être créer une sorte de rupture en
vous qui va vous pousser à faire un
changement donc mon changement à moi il
a démarré au début il y a
il ya démarré en suivant le lasser on va
dire j'ai pris la chaussure et je suis
allé au bout donc j'ai fait des voyages
en inde en afrique
j'ai fait des voyages dans le maghreb et
parfois j'ai fait des voyages juste à
côté de chez nous en france et c'était
toujours la même histoire il ya vingt
ans je consommais des produits tout
faits
j'en ai donné à mes enfants énormément
quand elle était petite elle mangeait
des barquettes avec les petites oreilles
là si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et
en fait j'avais une vie de working girl
dont je me disais j'ai pas le temps j'ai
le temps de rien faire à part d'aller à
l'hypermarché l'aller le club de gym
éventuellement etc
il ya 20 ans j'avais j'étais je venais
du marketing et j'avais pas du tout de
de questionnement sur ce qui était fait
pour moi tout était pratique c'était de
la nouveauté c'était fun donc je
consommais ça tranquillement et puis il
ya dix ans j'ai commencé à intégrer des
projets engagés comme la l'organisation
de la découverte écocitoyenne un salon
et là j'ai rencontré des gens qui me
parlait de responsabilité sociale de
responsabilité au niveau de
l'environnement
ils m'ont parlé de bio mais pour moi le
bio c'était un peu le mode hippie style
de vie où j'étais pas trop branché
surtout quand j'étais allé dans le
magasin bio pour la première fois
sincèrement ça n'avait pas donné
tellement envie je trouvais que les gens
lisent à une salle mines ça me donnait
pas tellement une manger ça donc du coup
que j'ai décidée c'est que en fait
j'allais me renseigner un peu plus qu'un
jour un copain m'a dit le bio c'est
simple en fait c'est juste que tu
m'épates chimie pour cultiver ou pour
élever ou très peu dans certains pays
donc obligatoirement c'est déjà ça de
pris pour ta santé
donc là j'ai commencé à adhérer au bio
et puis il ya sept ans je suis en j'ai
intégré une société qui crée des
filières équitables de t&d pis d'autres
produits qui viennent de loin et dont on
ne sait rien finalement
hélas la rupture a commencé à se créer
en moi je voyageais beaucoup j'y allais
voir des producteurs j'allais voir des
fournisseurs j'allais voir ce qui crée
les produits de l'autre côté je
discutais avec des acheteurs
les acheteurs des hypermarchés les
acheteurs des des restaurants des
restaurants les acheteurs des grossistes
les industriels j'ai rencontré tous ces
gens là et là j'ai commencé à perdre mes
repères
je ne pouvais pas ignorer que des les
hypermarchés prince tellement les
fabricants au niveau des prix que soit
il en crève
soit ils font n'importe quoi c'est pas
qu'ils ont envie de faire n'importe quoi
c'est juste le prix qu'il est prêt straw
d'un autre côté il y avait des marques
et marques connues un con qu'on utilise
beaucoup c'est marc larre exploite des
gens je ne pouvais plus supporter l'idée
que quand je donnais des gâteaux à
manger à mes enfants ont contribué à
détruire la matrice de la forêt primaire
d'indonésie parce que c'est la matrice
qui était en jeu c'est à dire c'était
même pas la forêt secondaires qu'on
était en train de détruire c'était la
matrice de la forêt primaire est une
matrice ça se reconstitue pas
donc tout ça c'était des informations
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
choquant
toutes ces choses là j'avais
l'impression qu'à chaque fois que
j'allais consommer un produit de ce type
j'allais avoir une escroquerie derrière
donc ça devenait compliqué seulement
quand on perd ses repères
il ya toujours cette phase où on sait
plus quoi faire parce que le temps je
l'avais pas comme tout le monde on
adapte ans c'est une maladie
occidentales on n'a jamais de temps donc
en fait le temps je l'avais pas pour
pour aller autre part que dans les
hypermarchés et l'argent je me disais le
bio ou l'achat direct c'est super cher
je peux pas faire ça quoi et puis
finalement j'ai commencé par éliminer
certains produits donc j'ai éliminé tout
ce qui était un peu extra c'est à dire
boissons gazeuses snack tous les trucs
que j'avais vu en fait en usine tout
simplement ce que plus je voyais les
matières premières plus je me dis waouh
c'est un peu choquant même ce qu'on
mange là donc on a j'ai éliminé ça
seulement le problème c'est la
résistance familiale parce que moi ok
j'avais vu dans les usines mais mes
enfants
elle s'en foutait un legato avec les
chevaliers là où c'est des trucs qui a
été le plus dur à éliminer de la cuisine
de mon placard et massa moi je savais
comment s'était fabriqué mais elle le
savait pas donc j'ai trouvé notre
méthode au début j'en aurais parlé puis
après finalement je me suis aperçu que
le mieux c'était encore de leur proposer
autre chose
c'est comme ça que j'ai fait j'ai fait
ce changement petit à petit j'ai
commencé à acheter des pâtes en italie
directement ça me permettait aussi de
ballades est un pur en italie j'ai
acheter du riz en camargue
j'ai acheté
des sauces tomate à des gens qui
faisaient attention à ce qui mettait
dedans j'ai acheté des jus par 24 à
pêche de vina de très très bons j'ai
acheter de la farine directement à
moulins et j'ai fait mes choix tout seul
c'est à dire qu'en fait j'avais envie
aussi d'apprendre ce que c'était que ces
produits parce que en faisant des achats
directs et un truc aussi qui est
important c'est que 1
vous savez à qui vous l'achetez ça c'est
plutôt sympa parce que maintenant je
suis vraiment ami avec tous les
producteurs et tous les produits que je
consomme bas derrière moyens visage et
deuxièmement il ya deuxième chose c'est
c'est de savoir comment sont faits les
produits parce que je ne sais pas si
vous êtes super expert des pois chiche
mais moi j'en avais jamais vu en culture
par exemple
donc j'ai commencé à me former là dessus
c'est comme ça que petit à petit le
changement s'est fait des exemples de
choses choquantes je pourrais vous en
donner des dizaines mais mon but c'est
vraiment pas de créer du stress en vous
mon but c'est de montrer que ça peut se
faire
et moi j'ai déserter totalement les
hypermarchés ça a pris sept ans mais
maintenant je suis super contente parce
que chaque achat que je fais et un
visage derrière il ya un impact c'est à
dire que j'ai repris mon pouvoir
j'en ai fait mon métier suite à ça parce
qu'en fait j'ai découvert que c'était un
vrai bonheur d'avoir un impact sur des
vies de gens donc gens j'ai créé un lieu
un lieu de découverte pour raconter
l'histoire de nombreux produits j'ai
également créé un film l'année dernière
avec un vidéaste professionnels et ce
film qui s'appelle graines d'espoir
parce que le but c'est vraiment
justement de retrouver son espoir donc
dans votre placard il ya tout ça ça
c'est très important
donc les choses soient ça que j'ai
appris c'est le changement ça se fait
petit à petit on a toujours tendance à
envie toujours tendance à avoir envie de
2 de secret un changement en deux
secondes
dire qu'on voudrait déjà passé 2 je fais
toutes mes courses à l'hypermarché
achevé plus aucune course et je boycotte
tout un tas de marque mais ça prends moi
ça m'a pris sept ans ça prend beaucoup
de temps et se pavane de se mettre la
pression en fait une chose après l'autre
et tout va bien souvent quand il ya un
problème on a tendance à en fait
à faire une montagne du problème alors
que finalement en essayant en essayant
c'est simple je vous assure il faut
vraiment essayer
or souvent on me dit tu me donnes ta
liste de producteurs là comme ça je vais
faire mon marché des producteurs
mais non c'est complètement débile parce
qu'en fait l'huile d'olive que j'achète
moins peut-être que vous les avez pas
vous cela fait peut-être que le gars qui
lui a produit bain pour vous les moins
sympathiques ça va pas devenir un copain
alors que pour moi c'est vraiment devenu
des amis donc fait ce chemin vous même
pour moi donc la vie est simple on a
toujours tendance à se la rendre
compliqué en fait les choses sont super
simple n'y a pas cinquante produits de
courant qu'on consomme 1 s'est vite fait
donc si vous regardez la liste des
produits principaux beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut trouver en france ont déjà
chaque geste ce que je fais a un impact
sur la vie de gens ça c'est l'impact
ça c'est primordial c'est à dire qu'on a
toujours l'impression que pour changer
il faut voter
donc ça c'est un moyen de changer c'est
sûr mais l'impact qu'on a quand on fait
nos courses mais vous n'êtes même pas
idée c'est à dire que quand on achète
quelque chose il ya vraiment des vies de
gens qui sont en jeu
moi je l' ai vécu tout le temps mais
dans les filières des pistes dans lequel
je travaille dans les filières de poids
je peux vous dire qu'un geste d'achat
est vraiment une signature en bas d'un
contrat est super important
résister c'est bon pour le moral ça vous
dit pas de retrouver votre puissance et
ne pas subir on fait pas tout bien moi
je suis vraiment pas une spécialiste de
tout bien il ya des trucs que je
consomme qui sont assez pourri en fait
je le sais d'ailleurs mais la différence
c'est qu'avant je subissais alors que
maintenant je choisis mes imperfections
ça c'est très différent moi je dis
toujours à mes filles aux et au pire ça
pourrait marcher
voilà je pense que c'est un truc c'est
vraiment un réflexe qu'il faut faire on
essaye le truc qui ça marche pas on
revient en arrière c'est pas grave et la
liberté voilà ça c'est ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que vraiment agir s'est
retrouvé sa liberté s'est retrouvé son
pouvoir se sentir fort en fait changé
c'est bon c'est bon pour le moral
donc voilà en tout cas
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que je
fais pas tout bien mais moi je suis
hyper contente je kiffe ma life comme
dirait florence foresti une nouvelle
fois parce qu'en fait je pense que le
monde il est en train de changer
moi je suis plutôt optimiste de nature
mais vraiment je le sens je sens que si
on est tous là aujourd'hui c'est que le
changement il est en route et qu'on a
tous envie etc avoir voté on a tous
envie vraiment donc ce que j'espère
juste c'est que ce soir en rentrant chez
vous quand vous allez ouvrir un de vos
placards
vous allez le regarder autrement
j'espère vraiment que ce placard là
maintenant pour vous ce sera un espoir
de changement
merci
[Applaudissements]